Let's go next to the caller calling in from
the four seven, eight area code.
Who's calling in today from four, seven eight.
Hi, yes, my name is Jamie and I'm calling
from Georgia.
Great to hear.
Well, thank you so much.
I'll watch your show all the time.
Uh, my question is at this point, you know,
we have elected officials going on TV saying
they absolutely will not uphold their oath
of office because they're going to cover up
or at what point do we as citizens have enough
legal basis to follow civil suit against these
people that are basically causing all of us
harm?
You know, would there be heist,
I mean, listen, we probably already have a
basis to do it in the sense that the interest
of the American people have not really been
represented by our elected officials for a
very long time.
The thing is though, as soon as you do it,
what, what court is going to allow that to
move forward, right?
And even if you get some lower court to allow
it to move forward, uh, where it's just an
unfortunately because what you are, what you're
trying to fight, Tammy is the system that
has put in place those who control every aspect
of the judiciary, the executive branch, the
legislative.
So we probably already have a basis to Sue
on that, uh, on those grounds.
But it's just not going to go anywhere.
Unfortunately.
I see.
You know, it, it just does feel like, you
know, at this point, you know, we can impeach
and we can do all this up there or we can
try as we are now.
But uh, it does start to, at what point does
it fit too much in our favor, you know, and
that a suit might at least bring some attention
to the fact that there are other ramifications
for their behavior.
I wish you were right.
I think, I think it would go nowhere.
But while I have you on the phone, since you're
calling from Georgia, what's going on with
the voter suppression there?
We've reported, you know, that hundreds of
thousands of people are attempted to be purged
from the voter rolls and that it's getting
continuing to be really ugly.
Is there anything new going on you can tell
me about?
Well, I can definitely say, you know, during
the last election I live in a predominantly
Republican County and we had, you know, like
six voting places.
It was very easy for you in a Republican part
of the state to get to get to vote and to
not have a long line it sounds like.
Yeah.
Oh, it it awfully.
So just in a place where I both, there were
six functioning machines.
Okay.
You know, and we, we didn't, you know, we're
a small County, you know, we, we only have,
I would say less than 15,000 in our County
total.
And you know, but I do know a few people that
have been bumped off.
I personally haven't because I'm an avid boater.
Right.
You know, so I think they can't meet, even
though I'm sure they would love to, you know?
Well, the good news that is that if you live
in a red part of Georgia, you are going to
have problem voting in November.
That's the good news, I guess.
Ah, yes.
You know, I guess that's about the best you
can get from it.
Yeah.
All right.
Tammy, really appreciate hearing from you.
Yeah.
It sounds like we're going to keep covering.
All right.
Thank you so much.
All right, Tammy from Georgia.
Great to hear from her.